Bienvenido al vídeo, en el cual vamos a explicar,
¿qué son las funciones?
Cuando yo aprendí este tema de funciones,
la verdad me fue un poco confuso,
porque pues no entendía
muy bien de qué se trataban
y tampoco entendía por qué se estudiaban.
Así que en este vídeo espero poder explicarte un poco,
de qué se tratan las funciones
y también pues contarte un poco
porque pueden ser útiles.
Bueno, vamos a empezar con lo siguiente.
Una función necesita una entrada,
un valor que le vamos a dar
y a ese valor déjame ponerle "x",
aquí voy a poner una "x".
Y más o menos, la idea de una función,
es que es algo así como una caja sorpresa,
o sea este valor de "x",
lo vamos a meter aquí en una caja...
en una caja,
que se llama "f",
así le vamos a llamar a la función
y esa función "f" lo que hace es,
convertir esta "x" en otra cosa
y sacar un resultado.
Y a ese resultado que obtenemos,
le vamos a llamar "f" de "x",
¿vale?
Entonces quizás hasta ahorita,
todavía las cosas son un poco confusas,
porque hay muchos símbolos esta "x", "f" y "f" de "x",
así que vamos a hacer un ejemplo concreto.
Imaginemos que lo que hace esta caja sorpresa,
es lo siguiente,
¿qué hace?
Que a la entrada ósea "f" de "x",
la eleva al cuadrado y le suma 1.
¿Vale?
entonces esta es la reglita que tenemos que seguir,
por ejemplo,
supongamos que nos preguntan quién es "f" de 2...
"f" de 2,
entonces, para respondernos esta pregunta,
lo que hay que pensar es que aquí está entrando un 2,
a esta caja
y que aquí está saliendo algún resultado,
que ahorita no sabemos quién es,
pero para saber quién es,
simplemente debemos de poner este 2,
aquí arriba y a ver qué pasa.
entonces si ponemos el 2 aquí,
nos queda 2 al cuadrado que es 4
y si sumamos 1 nos da 5,
entonces "f" de 2 sería igual a 5,
y me puedes decir,
óyeme,
esto nada más es una forma más complicada,
de sustituir un valor en una ecuación
o en una expresión,
y bueno, sí,
hasta ahorita te voy a dar la razón,
pero puede ser que una función sea una expresión un poco más general, que una ecuación,
¿a qué me refiero?
por ejemplo,
imaginate que tenemos la siguiente función,
tenemos la función "f" de "x"...
"f" de "x" es igual...
le voy a poner aquí "x" cuadrada más 1,
si x es par...
si x es...
par...
y voy a ponerle aquí abajo,
"x" cuadrada menos 1,
si "x" es impar...
impar...
Muy bien,
entonces observa, esto de aquí es algo nuevo,
no simplemente nos dice,
cuál es la expresión que tenemos que evaluar,
sino que además nos da instrucciones
dependiendo el valor de "x",
lo que tenemos que hacer.
Por ejemplo,
si aquí nos piden calcular cuánto es "f" de 2...
"f" de 2...
Entonces,
tendríamos que utilizar el primer caso,
cuando "x" es par
y nos quedaría igual a...
a ver 2 al cuadrado es 4 más 1 es 5,
eso ya lo habíamos hecho antes,
pero si pusiéramos aquí "f" de 3,
entonces, ahora tendríamos que hacer,
3 al cuadrado y restarle 1,
en el segundo caso.
Entonces 3 al cuadrado es 9,
si restamos 1 nos quedaría 8.
Muy bien, entonces como ves, esto es algo un poquito
más abstracto o un poquito más inusual,
que el ejemplo anterior.
¿vale?
bueno, vamos a ver otros ejemplos,
quiero darte un ejemplo un poco raro o un poco... éste, abstracto,
para pues contarte un poco más
de qué se trata esto de las funciones,
realmente hay muchas cosas en el mundo
que se pueden pensar como funciones.
A lo mejor es un poquito confuso,
pero no te preocupes si te confundes,
en realidad los problemas que nos van a poner,
o que ponen en los exámenes son más sencillos.
Bueno,
pero para mostrarte que es una idea más general,
déjame pensar en esta función,
que le voy a llamar Leo...
Leo...
yo me llamo Leo,
¿vale?
entonces esto va a ser la caja sorpresa,
y vamos a pensar qué sucede
si le ponemos como entrada,
a esta función que se llama Leo,
comida...
comida,
¿entonces que puede producir Leo?
ahorita no me voy a meter
en todas las cosas que puede producir Leo,
más bien quiero decir algo específico,
entonces, lo que me voy a preguntar es,
¿quién es Leo?
o ¿qué es Leo?
de comida...
comida...
y bueno, si tú me das de comer,
entonces yo puedo producir,
videos traducidos de La Academia Khan
entonces déjame ponerle por aquí...
vídeos...
videos...
de La Academia Khan...
traducidos...
¿vale?
entonces misma idea
entra comida
y salen vídeos de La Academia Khan,
traducidos,
claro,
a lo mejor además de poner comida necesitamos,
pues aquí una computadora verdad...
una computadora...
computadora...
para pues realmente poder producir los vídeos.
En fin,
vamos a pensarlo así.
Bueno, vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Vamos a poner ahora la función tú
digo, podría poner tu nombre,
no lo sé... estaría padre saberlo,
pero déjame ponerle nada más tú.
Entonces qué sucede contigo, o sea,
qué sucede con ahora la función que se llama tú
vamos a pensar qué sucede,
cuando de entrada,
tiene videos de La Academia Khan,
videos de La Academia Khan,
traducidos...
voy a poner nada más así ¡tras!
traducidos.
Bueno, pues con un poco de suerte si,
si entran vídeos de La Academia Khan, a ti,
pues vas a aprender cosas
y con eso vas a sacar exámenes con 10.
Entonces lo voy a poner aquí, exámenes....
exámenes, con 10 de calificación
le voy a poner tus exámenes, ¿si'
no los exámenes de tus amigos ni de nadie más,
sino tus exámenes con 10 ¿va?
Ahora, bueno, sabes qué, déjame aquí quitar
la computadora para pensar en lo siguiente,
imagínate que ahora lo que queremos hacer es,
preguntarnos el resultado de la siguiente operación
o sea imagínate que queremos ver,
quién sería tu...
de Leo...
de comida...
comida...
¿va?
esto de aquí ya se está poniendo un poco ridículo,
pero sigue la corriente tantito,
porque esto tiene una idea interesante detrás.
Entonces ve,
ya sabemos que Leo de comida
es videos de La Academia Khan traducidos,
y sabemos que tú,
de vídeos de La Academia Khan traducidos,
es que tus exámenes tienen 10,
o que puedes producir sus exámenes,
con 10 de calificación.
Entonces,
¿qué pasaría aquí?
¿que obtenemos si hacemos tú, de Leo, de comida?
pues bueno aquí adentro tendríamos que ver quién es Leo, de comida ,
entonces esto que no sabemos cuánto es,
pues primero tenemos que ver,
cuánto es Leo de comida,
voy a ponerle por acá,
Leo de comida
y ya sabemos que esto es, videos...
videos de La Academia Khan traducidos,
entonces tú, de Leo, de comida,
sería lo mismo que tú,
de videos...
videos...
de La Academia Khan traducidos
y tú de videos, ya sabemos cuánto es,
tú de vídeos...
es que en tus exámenes sacas 10,
entonces puedes producir tus exámenes...
exámenes...
con 10...
con 10.
Muy bien, entonces tú, de Leo, de comida,
es que es producir tus exámenes con 10.
Eso está padrísimo
y si aquí en vez de comida le pusiéramos,
otra cosa, no sé, si en vez de comida pensamos,
que aquí le ponemos veneno,
pues sería algo muy distinto verdad,
aquí en vez de que entre comida,
entraría veneno.
Tendríamos que ver cuánto es Leo de veneno...
veneno...
entonces
¿qué podría producir yo si me das veneno?
Pues no sé, pero definitivamente,
no serían vídeos de La Academia Khan traducidos
y entonces sería muy distinto.
No, no, no te recomiendo que me des veneno...
bueno...
Ok, entonces a lo mejor
este ejemplo es un poco raro,
pero no te preocupes, o sea,
si no lo entendiste nada más la idea es
ver que hay más cosas en el mundo,
que pueden servir como funciones.
Vamos a hacer mejor un ejemplo, ahora sí,
con números y con expresiones,
siguiendo estas mismas ideas.
No sé, imagínate,
imagínate que nos dicen que la función "f",
"f" de "x" es igual a "x" más 2,
y que la función "g" de "x" es igual a...
pues le voy a poner "x" cuadrada menos 1.
Entonces pregunta,
¿cuánto sería "g" de "f" de 3?
¿Cómo le haríamos para calcular esta expresión?
Le voy a poner aquí
un signo de interrogación...
ah, pues misma idea,
primero tenemos que evaluarlo de aquí adentro,
que es "f" de 3,
déjame hacer "f" de 3 aquí al lado,
entonces teníamos que ver cuánto es "f" de 3,
y para eso sustituimos 3 en esta expresión,
3 más 2 sería 5...
sería 5,
entonces "g" de "f" de 3,
sería igual a "g" de 5
y ahora este 5 lo podemos sustituir en esta expresión,
en esta función,
para ver que nos queda.
Entonces nos quedaría, 5 al cuadrado menos 1,
que es 25 menos 1, o sea 24
y de esta forma sabemos que "g" de "f" de 3,
es igual a, 24.
Muy bien, bueno, espero que estas ideas te ayuden
un poco a comprender esto de las funciones
espero no haberte espantado mucho con ese ejemplo,
de los vídeos traducido y de la comida
y del veneno, en fin,
en los siguientes vídeos
vamos a ver un poco más de ejemplos
y bueno, con un poco de suerte en el camino,
entenderemos un poco mejor,
de qué se trata esto de las funciones.
Bueno, hasta la próxima.